try to act surprised al pacino didn't
really snort cocaine in Scarface just as
shootouts in movies are all staged the
countless drugs consumed on screen over
the years aren't real prop masters have
come up with all kinds of crazy
concoctions to make cinematic contraband
look as close as possible to the real
thing we're about to narc on all the
fake drugs you see on the silver screen
oh and just so we're clear don't take
any drugs authentic or otherwise don't
smoke crack
marijuana let's start things off with
weed veteran Hollywood prop master Jeff
butcher revealed to upvoted that he's
ordered fake marijuana also known
hilariously as wizard weed from a
company called international oddities so
he could stuff bags of movie weed how
kind is their fake bud they provided the
prop marijuana and pineapple Express on
James Franco's personal recommendation
for scenes featuring joints most movies
use either wizard weed or herbal
cigarettes while we're on the subject
remember that awesome scene in zombie
land where the characters get high and
do well this
[Music]
[Music]
sorry to disappoint you but that smoke
was produced by the inside of plain old
herbal cigarettes dumped into a hookah
the fake stuff might not leave you
creating Funyuns but it certainly looks
the part
cocaine the Hollywood version of coke is
pretty harmless to an extent during a
Q&A session hosted by Bryan Cranston
Jonah Hill revealed just what happened
to him on the set of Wolff Wall Street
after he snorted too much of the fake
stuff I got bronchitis per month and a
half for a week because the cocaine that
we snorted it was vitamin B and I had
snorted so much vitamin B that my lungs
had got infected with bronchitis and I
was sick for a month and a half and
while Jeff butcher says that vitamin B
is one of the most commonly used cocaine
substitutes for movies prop masters have
turned to all kinds of other
alternatives when making onset powder
other films have used mixtures of baking
soda powdered sugar and powdered milk to
get things just right but Scarface
co-star Stephen Bauer once revealed just
what it was that covered Tony Montana's
desk baby laxative that explains a lot
if you had to snort that much baby
laxative you'd probably react this way
too
heroin just like Hollywood spade cocaine
common household items and cooking
ingredients are often mixed and put into
baggies to simulate heroin of course
things get a little trickier when movie
show people taking close-up injections
of the junk in an interview with The
Daily Beast prop master Gordon
Fitzgerald explained how they film the
heroin injection scenes in Danny Boyle's
train spotting from 1996 Fitzgerald
recalled taking a slightly dyed liquid
and injecting it into an artificial arm
of course these prosthetics have makeup
and a small amount of hair applied and
even fake blood to make you forget that
you're watching make-believe cigarettes
for decades cigarettes featured on film
were the real thing until the government
and tobacco companies clashed over
product placement rules for potentially
harmful substances studies found that
for younger viewers watching character
smoking movies often increase the
likelihood of picking up the habit in
real life fake e-cigarette smoking is a
lot tougher than you might realize
just as they're used to simulate pot
herbal cigarettes have become the go-to
choice especially for shows like Mad Men
but sometimes other alternatives are
necessary
Jeff butcher explained that the prop
Department on 2014's non-stop made
hand-rolled cigarettes filled with
chamomile tea for former smoker Liam
Neeson alcohol while alcohol is
perfectly legal you don't want your
actors getting sloshed after the 12th
take various teas are served at room
temperature to simulate the darker forms
of the hard stuff to replace beer films
usually just rely on non-alcoholic brews
like O'Doul's clear drinks like vodka
tend to be just water but off-color
shots usually have to be a mix of
different liquids like apple juice and
Pellegrino then again rumor has it the
John Belushi's whiskey jug and animal
house was real and we can't help loving
him even more for it thanks I needed
that
meThe the Hollywood version of crank ice
meth or whatever the kids call nowadays
isn't real either
a behind the scenes AMC video reveals
that the meth featured on Breaking Bad
is actually homemade rock candy and as
actor Bryan Cranston explains in this
Entertainment Weekly video the sweet
stuff can be just as addictive but on
nights when it's is labor intensive and
sixteenth hour we start take it out of
sugar of course getting people hooked on
rock candy makes perfect sense for the
guy who used to play a TV dentist thanks
for watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know which item on the list
fooled you the most
[Music]